Iko Dina Moreira
and her friends put lots of energy into
performing Kate Varian batuque gay music
we're in the small community of chalkin
solvus about 25 kilometers away from the
capital of Cape Verde praia
this town was only connected to the
electricity grid around a year ago that
brought changes for the whole community
Eagle Deena for instance bought a
washing machine which saves her a lot of
time since then the family's electricity
bill has come to about 24 euros a month
and the new refrigerator means she's now
able to keep food fresh and even save
some money every month
Yasha
Al Gore economy's Amish whoo I think now
I save more money in Al damage ever
because at the end of the month all my
salary used to be spent on that brought
me a bag of rice would not last for a
whole month it would last only for 15
days but now even though it won't last
until the end of the month but to 20 or
22 days we can now cook and then store
the food in the fridge the boys what I
did
Cape Verde is an archipelago this makes
it difficult to produce and distribute
energy since the 10 islands are spread
far apart
to be independent from the import of
expensive fossil fuels the government is
investing in locally abundant renewable
resources Sun and of course wind this
wind farm in Santiago with 11 turbines
is owned by public private company Kavya
Lisa
it contributes around 16% of the
electricity consumed on the island as
engineer on a montero explains where
there locally the ALP reproduce and
energy AOH Betty is an ideal location to
produce wind energy because the wind is
quite strong it's suitable for this
production and fairly constant that
allows quite reliable wind power
production they are like okay by
Santiago and with the additional power
Montero expects fewer energy blackouts
on the island although they'll still
have to invest in infrastructure the
company hopes to reduce energy costs for
the consumer in the long term a dumbshit
in sodom this is what we are trying to
solve at the moment to use more of this
resource and at the same time to always
protect the bottom line ions if it's a
challenge to do that because the cost of
these technologies is also enormous yes
them being sewing arms the energy mix of
the country covers 94% of its territory
but where the power grid has not yet
been connected like a Joe Diaz farm
small private solutions are necessary he
produces mainly manioc carrots and
sugarcane and wants to expand production
therefore he plans to invest in
renewable energy he already has a small
solar system installed at his house so
far this provides just enough energy to
pump water for the family and the
animals
then we wished men penis y'all the
initial investment can be high but over
time it's more economical because it has
less maintenance and it lasts for more
years and either by me the Sun has gone
down in Cape Verde but the wind turbines
remain in operation and in the village
Eagle Deena and the other buck 2k
singers continue performing in the
market square after dark power cuffs
here have grown rare under the for
electricity came we couldn't do things
like this once it was dark because we
couldn't see each other can walk there
was no stopping it